in england there is growing backlash and
excitement for what's
shaping up to be a transatlantic fight
over prince harry and meghan markle sit
down with oprah winfrey
that will be seen right here on cbs in
an apparent sighting with the royal
family the british media are suggesting
it's insensitive to air such an
explosive interview while prince philip
is still
in the hospital harry's grandfather was
transferred overnight to a private
hospital
after undergoing a heart procedure at
age 99.
mts taeyab is outside buckingham palace
with the very latest
i wasn't even allowed to have that
conversation with you personally
right there had to be people from the
comp sitting there everything
there were other people in the room when
i was having that conversation that
bombshell answer was given after oprah
asked megan
why the couple decided to give their
first interview after stepping back as
working royals
now megan's jaw-dropping response has
sparked a media frenzy
and said alarm bells ringing among royal
circles
you can only imagine how that's going to
go down in palace circles not well at
all there will i'm sure be retaliations
and push back on that
according to megan this is what
retaliation looks like
just days after the couple's interview
was announced buckingham palace made its
own announcement
saying it was opening an investigation
into claims from back in 2018
that megan bullied royal staff
allegations the duchess is calling the
quote
latest attack on her character we knew
their split from the royal family as
official working roars was painful
on both sides but no one i think could
have foreseen that a year on we would be
in
full blown mudslinging trans-atlantic
mudslinging
here in the uk some of that mud has come
in the form
of concern concern over the timing of
the interview
a day after it was announced and weeks
after it was recorded
the queen's husband 99 year old prince
philip was admitted into hospital for a
heart condition
but for harry and megan it's clear that
the gloves are now
off and little will stop them from
telling their side
of the story in another sign this
bare-knuckle fight is only getting
bloodier the u.k government's top
charity regulator has announced it's
opening an investigation into the
couple's sussex royal organization
a charitable organization which hasn't
been operational
since last july for cbs this morning
saturday
mps tayyip london
mts thank you very much you can see all
of oprah's interview with megan and
harry tomorrow night at 8
eastern 7 central right here on
cbs you guys were discussing this
vigorously yes we are
well first higher piece we'll be
watching yeah there's nobody
watching it on pins and needles but i
mean everyone that i've been talking to
is
like this investigation they were like
where was the investigation on prince
andrew and his connection to jeffrey
epstein yeah
it seems in seeing it from afar to me
it's
is this trying to smear somebody taking
the attention away from it it just
it i don't know it just stands out not
not a good look we'll see what happens
my pr